John as well as John's in Georgia hi
John how are you hi Dave I'm doing
better than any of us deserve I guess
maybe else just the same sir how can I
help
well um quite some time ago my now
deceased ex-wife got a store credit card
it was American Eagle and bought herself
a pair of pants and a shirt this was
actually a little bit before we got
married
she got the card in my name and had it
sent to our you know had it sent to the
address we were getting ready to live
that and just through the bills away so
I never found out about this thing until
six years later seven years later so the
$68 in purchasing ended up they wanted
they sent me a bill for about $800 you
know started threatening to put liens on
trucks that I no longer owned and they
were going to garnish my wages and all
of that stuff and I talked to the debt
collector and I broke it I broke it in
half and they said you can settle for
this amount in two payments and so I
paid half one week and I paid half the
next week you know each check that I got
and I was done with it well now it's two
years later and some law firm is coming
at me the same kind of way they're you
know we're going to take you to court
we're gonna sue you
you're going to do this you're going to
do that and lastly I assume you didn't
get the other deal in writing that
that's settled the debt I got they
emailed me a confirmation number and
amazing a number of just just from but
it didn't state the terms that when you
pay these two payments you're clear hmm
if they did I don't have it um it just
gave me a confirmation I'm not getting
that done and not keeping up with it has
cost you the rest of this bill right so
there's it's I'm just wondering if
there's anything I can do pretty much to
just dump these guys on the head I
they don't know where I live they don't
have my actual email address have you
noticed that this is not going to go
away until you deal with it this thing's
haunted you for a freaking decade it's
three or four hundred bucks man so just
pay it off move on with your life if it
was thirty thousand dollars we talked
about putting some effort into it
but she took it out without your name
you married her you divorced her then
she died I mean this is Peyton Place by
the time we get through all this soap
opera we can't if at the time you're
divorced wife took out you stole your
identity then you could go at the moment
you found that out and go this is
identity theft I don't know a thing
which is technically the truth of this
story but good luck after all this soap
opera getting that to stick right you
have to file a police report on your
dead ex-wife yeah they ain't gonna work
man so I would just either either
negotiate a settlement with them and by
god this time get it in writing never
pay people on an old bad debt unless
you've got the deal in writing even if
you're paying them in full never pay
them unless you've got it in writing and
then keep a copy of the payment to show
that it went out and a copy of the
agreement stapled together hard copy not
electronic copy if it's an email printed
out staple the receipt from the wire
transfer or whatever it is you do keep
it in a file the rest of your life
because these people will hunt you down
27 years later yes I know about the
statute of limitations
I understand statute of limitations good
luck you're dealing people they're gonna
hassle your butt and you're gonna have
to go to court over $300 oh no just
settle the thing get out of your life
but listen not dealing with it is not a
strategy hiding from it ducking saying
I'm off the grid is not a strategy it's
a little tough stay off the grid in
today's world